Senator Bernie Sanders has endorsed the
re-election campaign of President Joe
Biden and says he will not run in 2024.
many people emailed me tweeted to me
they sent me smoke signals they sent me
telegrams they faxed me uh opinions that
Bernie is somehow being forced or
strong-armed into endorsing Joe Biden
why
and what evidence of that do you have
well the DNC Force the there's no
evidence whatsoever Bernie Sanders is
his own man
Bernie Sanders is in his 80s he has had
an incredibly successful career as a
lawmaker why on Earth would he feel
strong-armed into endorsing Joe Biden
and for what
so if you have evidence that that's what
happened I want to hear it but my view
is I believe Bernie call me crazy when I
hear from Bernie his explanation I
understand it